bueno le doy la bienvenida nuestro
invitado ricardo gonzález periodista
magíster en estudios políticos y creador
del programa de debate de jóvenes en el
andén ricardo gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de francés
de 4 un día ahora raúl saludo para
ustedes para todos los televidentes de
france 24 y con mucha ansiedad estamos
estos días en colombia definiendo cómo
va a quedar la primera vuelta
presidencia vamos a verlo el domingo 29
de mayo ricardo porque quiero preguntar
entonces teniendo en cuenta el tema de
hoy de los jóvenes cómo van a votar cómo
se mueven cómo ha evolucionado y cómo es
el papel de los jóvenes en la política
colombiana pues nos sorprendieron a
todos los jóvenes en 2021 incluso había
ya un precedente del 2019 en el paro
nacional que fueron ellos los
protagonistas quizás hoy un poquito más
atrás 2018 cuando las protestas de
manifestaciones en colombia el paro de
los universitarios 2019 un paro nacional
incentivado motivado por lo que había
pasado anteriormente en el estallido
social de chile y en 2021 el estallido
más grande que ha vivido colombia en su
historia reciente
protagonizado justamente por los jóvenes
por supuesto que existe la ley y la
conclusión de que hubo violencia de xbox
esos de algunos de los jóvenes esa
imagen de la primera línea que veíamos
también en chile pero los protagonistas
los jóvenes que manifestaron paz y se
manifestaron pacíficamente con
expresiones artísticas pues había que
oírlos y había que verlos de alguna
manera y eso seguramente esos que se
llaman primo votantes que hace cuatro
años tenían 17 16 años y hoy ya pueden
votar pues seguramente van a ser una
proporción importante más o menos 3
millones de jóvenes nuevos que podrán
definir la elección de hoy la gran
pregunta la pregunta del millón es irán
a las urnas si esa es esa molestia que
estaba en las calles hace exactamente un
año por estos días se va a traducir en
en emitir su voto este próximo domingo
riccardo ya que se debe ese despertar de
los jóvenes desde el año 2018 como se lo
decía ahí hay una hay una razón de peso
y es el inconformismo con el de con el
gobierno actual el inconformismo con el
gobierno del presidente iván duque esa
idea antisistema que ha calado tan
fuerte entre entre los jóvenes y eso se
ha traducido indiscutiblemente
que vea en una figura como la del
senador gustavo petro quien los pueda
representar a ellos para esta próxima
elección las cifras lo dicen por lo
menos en las encuestas que han sido
publicadas en la última semana esta
semana ya no se puede publicar la
encuesta por vía electoral de 18 a 24
años gustavo petro tiene el 53 por
ciento de intención de voto es un
fenómeno naturalmente gustado petro
entre los jóvenes si fuera por los
jóvenes petro ganaría este domingo en
primera vuelta pero también es raúl hay
que ver el impacto que ha tenido alguien
como el ingeniero rodolfo hernández que
aquí en colombia se le ha catalogado
para que toda nuestra audiencia lo puede
identificar como el trump criollo y el
trump creo yo el ingeniero rodolfo
hernández que por su movimiento tan
activo en redes sociales específicamente
en tick tock ha generado un interés
bastante importante en un grupo de
jóvenes que son antisistema pero que nos
identifican con gustavo p ricardo y por
qué los jóvenes como usted lo dijo de 18
a 24 años se decantan por el candidato
gustavo petro cuáles son estas políticas
que pues enriquecen no esté esta
intención de voto de esa es logro de
gustado petro tiene claras las agendas
del siglo 21 y eso por supuesto hace un
clic de inmediato con los jóvenes cambio
climático una transición energética en
serio qué es lo que plantea gustado
petro obviamente con un revuelo
impresionante que causó en colombia'
decir el primer día se suspende la
exploración de petróleo no la
explotación que ya está lista sino la
exploración también lo que tiene que ver
con las los temas de género su
vicepresidenta es una activa una
activista clara de esos temas de género
y también la lucha por la desigualdad
una lucha por la equidad que también con
la que también los jóvenes se
identifican entonces creo que hay en ese
clic que hace pero con esos agentes del
siglo 21 pues los los conquistas el otro
discurso el discurso anticorrupción el
discurso antisistema se lo está ganando
de alguna manera rodolfo hernández y por
eso si es eso se hace en su vertiginoso
de en las últimas semanas riccardo las
demandas concretas de los jóvenes para
esta elección porque un cambio inmediato
y contundente además también le quiero
preguntar el próximo presidente puede
generar ese cambio que los jóvenes
quieren para allá esa es una gran
pregunta y raúl porque muchos están
diciendo listo damos por sentado que
ganó gustado petro el domingo en la
elección de junio que puede pasar que en
colombia va a ser muy difícil es lograr
esas transformaciones de inmediato hay
un congreso existen unos unos grupos de
interés que van a tratar de hacer lo
posible porque esos cambios no se den y
cuando estos jóvenes
raúl de 18 a 24 años incluso los que
vienen atrás empiecen a ver que los
cambios no se pueden dar pues puede
ocurrir otro estallido social de dicen
diciendo yo te por petro pero me
decepcione porque no pudo hacerlo que lo
que queríamos o en el otro escenario de
que no gane petro de que no nos gustado
petro sea con un manto de duda porque
exista un fraude
puede que se trate de mover esa retórica
de que exista un fraude electoral o
genuinamente no gane pues esa olla a
presión puede estallar nuevamente en
algún momento como lo decía alejandro
gaviria hace unos días ese volcán sobre
el que estamos parados puede estallar o
puede hacer erupción en algún momento
con los jóvenes otra vez como
protagonistas porque el hartazgo de los
jóvenes ricardo se puede decir que
solamente fue por el gobierno de
presidente y van creo que fue estalló
con el presidente de duke y justamente
porque en medio de una pandemia propone
con suministro de hacienda una reforma
tributaria que iba a llevar a que
incluso los jóvenes que estaban
empezando a trabajar que estaban
empezando a surgir que un joven de 25 a
30 años que ya tenía un salario pues le
iban a cobrar un impuesto de renta a él
un impuesto equivalente
en equivalencia igual a los más ricos
del país eso hizo estallar una
inconformidad que por supuesto venía de
hace más o menos 30 años en colombia que
le falta a la juventud colombiana a su
parecer para ser más contundente en la
política y también le quiero preguntar
si esto es algo momentáneo o este
movimiento de la juventud es como una
bola de nieve que va a ir cosa que
digamos estas elecciones va a ir
creciendo creciendo creciendo creciendo
hasta que van a ser parte fundamental de
la política y los cambios que va a tener
que tener colombia yo creo que la
información que vemos a través de las
redes sociales un joven coge toma un
celular
de 50 años detectó y ahí ve mucho
contenido político por supuesto se va a
inmiscuyendo se va informando y va a ser
muy difícil desconectar los despegar los
de esa de esa conexión ya con está híper
conexión que va a cada vez va a ser va a
ser más grande nos enfrentaremos también
por supuesto a las noticias falsas
siento yo creo que esa conexión de los
jóvenes con la política de hacer cada
vez mayor cada vez más continente va a
haber más veeduría ciudadana por parte
de ellos y ya lo vimos en las elecciones
del congreso de marzo pasado hubo muchos
jóvenes hubo mucho activista que estaba
en esa lógica de estar en el paro
nacional de estarse manifestando que se
transformó que tradujo esa indignación
en ser juristas el ejemplo de una de las
jóvenes de medellín una zona de colombia
que es muy conservadora pero que eligió
como representante a la cámara a una
joven activista que simplemente estuvo
dirigiendo una orquesta de violinistas
en el paro nacional a través de eso se
expresó con su música y hoy eso iba a
ser congresista la república digamos en
las elecciones del domingo y va a ser
mayor el porcentaje de los jóvenes que
van a votar o vamos a tener también
jóvenes que todavía no van a estar
decididos que van a preferir abstención
en esta primera vuelta y ya ir con más
seguridad en una segunda vuelta cómo
vamos a poder ver este panorama digamos
en el voto de la juventud para el
próximo domingo 29 veía en la nota muy
interesante desde desde cali que
quedabas a esa mirada de todos los
jóvenes los que están con fisco los que
están con petro y esa otra de los
abstencionistas que por supuesto una
proporción gigantesca en colombia o está
más o menos del 46 por ciento y en los
jóvenes esa esa proporción es es mucho
más alta los jóvenes fueron
protagonistas raúl hace 12 años cuando
impulsaron la llamada ola verde la
campaña gigantesca por antanas mockus en
ese momento para irse contra el
candidato de álvaro uribe y todos
pensábamos va a ganar y antanas mockus
porque las encuestas lo social y no
fueron a votar los jóvenes los jóvenes
se quedaron simplemente en facebook en
ese momento entonces esa es la gran
pregunta si van a ser
votantes en el próximo domingo o se van
a quedar simplemente en tick tock en
twitter en las redes sociales la
abstención es una de las preguntas del
millón que habrá que resolver a partir
del próximo domingo cuando uno empiece a
cotejar las cifras de las de votación
aquí votaron jóvenes aquí no tan jóvenes
de esta mesa era sólo de jóvenes y
quedaron sin votos y el abstencionismo
de ser muy importante y en eso hay un
punto supremamente interesante que es la
campaña que promueve sofía petro la hija
de gustavo petro que también estábamos
viendo en la nota que obviamente ella
tiene su apellido marcado que es la hija
de petro pero está impulsando una
campaña de diciéndole a los jóvenes oiga
la primera no se olvida la primera
votación la primera vez que usted va a
las urnas no se olvide así que vaya a
votar da una cifra que llamaba mucho la
atención sobre esto por sobre este tema
del abstencionismo y es que 470 mil
jóvenes no han ido a reclamar su cédula
tenían todos estos días para hacerlo
entonces hay a usted le da una idea de
que no están realmente y no estarían
realmente interesados en votar el
próximo domingo en todo caso todo lo
vamos a saber como usted lo dijo el
próximo domingo 29 de mayo ricardo
muchísimas gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa
raúl a usted muchas gracias por esta
invitación y por estar tan atentos de lo
que va a pasar en la elección de
colombia de primera vuelta este domingo